Et regardez le château là.
_ Il est beau !
_ On dirait un château de chevaliers !
_ D'inspiration italienne la construction
de ce château a duré plus de 150 ans,
156 m de façade, 4 grosses tours d'angle,
des tourelles qui s'élancent dans le ciel,
Chambord et le plus grandiose des châteaux
de la Loire...
La visite coûte 13€ par adulte.
La famille a réservé un guide
pour un supplément de 5€ par personne.
Il s'appelle Aurélien et va les emmener
dans un voyage au cœur de l'histoire.
_ On vient de rentrer dans le château.
Qu'est ce qu'on voit en premier
quand on entre dans le château de Chambord ?
_ De grands escaliers !
_ Les enfants, je vous propose
qu'on fasse un petit jeu.
Vous allez monter
et vous vous arrêter à la première fenêtre.
Avec vos parents
on va monter de l'autre côté.
Allez-y !
_ Cet escalier est unique à Chambord.
On l'appelle l'escalier à double révolution.
On y monte et on y descend sans jamais
se croiser, grâce à 2 rampes distinctes.
Le centre est creux, des fenêtres
ont été placées les unes en face des autres.
Toute la petite famille peut se voir.
_ Alors on va monter les étages.
_ Les enfants montent de plus en plus vite,
ils veulent arriver les premiers tout en haut.
Mais c'était sans compter sur la rapidité
de leur papa arrivé avant eux.
_ Et voilà, on se rejoint !
_ Encore !
_ Tout en haut, on arrive !
La récompense, c'est maintenant sur l'une
des terrasses emblématiques du château.
Elle offre une vue imprenable
sur les jardins de 7 hectares
qui viennent juste d'être rénovés.
À Chambord, tout est démesuré,
y compris l'intérieur :
426 pièces, des suites royales,
les visiteurs peuvent même imaginer,
grâce à une application de réalité augmentée
ce qu'était la vie dans ce château
au XVIᵉ siècle.
La famille de Marlène et Michael va aussi
découvrir une des pièces
les plus énigmatiques de ce château si beau,
si imposant et si puissant
que le Roi Soleil s'y fît aménager
une chambre.
_ On arrive dans la chambre de Louis XIV,
regardez la petite balustrade.
Cela servait à séparer l'endroit où dormait
le roi, de l'espace, où tous les autres,
tous les invités pouvaient entrer
juste à côté du lit.
Vous voyez la petite porte qui est cachée ?
On a une pièce secrète ici
qui était réservée au roi...
On va y aller ensemble.
_ Une pièce secrète
uniquement réservée au roi.
Pour y arriver, il faut ressortir sur
la terrasse et ouvrir une porte
dont la clé est énorme.
C'est ici, dans cette pièce, que le roi
pouvait vivre à l'abri des regards.
_ C'était les parties privées
réservées au roi de France.
Et regardez, on a une petite porte
qui est cachée ici.
À votre avis
que va-t-on trouver derrière ?
_ Je ne sais pas !
_ Regardez, si j'ouvre...
Vous pouvez vous avancer.
Regardez où on est !
_ Retour à la case départ,
directement dans la chambre du roi.
La famille en prend plein les yeux.
_ On se sent vraiment tout petit, donc,
on laisse le décor opérer
et nous permettre de s'émerveiller.
_ Tandis que la famille part
vers d'autres aventures.
À quelques mètres de là,
sur une terrasse du château, voici Éric.
Il est chercheur et passionné d'histoire.
Il travaille à Chambord depuis 30 ans
et le seul à détenir le code secret
pour ouvrir les pièces du château
que le grand public ne peut pas encore voir.
_ Nous quittons les espaces publics
pour aller vers des espaces plus privés.
Une des missions d'Eric est de comprendre
à quoi servaient les combles du château.
_ On n'a pas de commentaire d'époque
sur les nobles vivant dans les combles.
Pourtant cela s'est fait.
En témoigne encore aujourd'hui la présence
d'énormes cheminées qui sont les mêmes
que dans les étages inférieurs.
Donc, on est dans les espaces
d'habitation nobles,
même dans les combles.
_ Sur une des terrasses, une porte dérobée
mène à la plus haute tour de Chambord.
Pour y monter, comme partout ailleurs dans
le château : des marches en tuffeau.
Une pierre très fragile.
Cette tour est la tour de la Lanterne
avec une immense fleur de lys à son sommet.
Très étroite, Éric tente de comprendre
son usage à l'époque de François Iᵉʳ.
Cette histoire, il voudrait un jour
la raconter aux visiteurs.
_ Aujourd'hui à 2 personnes, on est déjà
un peu serré lorsqu'on est au sommet...
On peut penser que c'est un endroit
très réservé, dont le roi fait seulement
les honneurs à quelques uns,
un ambassadeur, un souverain étranger
en visite dans les parages,
invité par François Iᵉʳ.
_ Aujourd'hui, rares sont ceux, qui ont
les honneurs de pénétrer dans cette tour,
toujours dans l'espoir de trouver
des financements et d'en raconter davantage
sur l'histoire des rois de France.
Elle sera peut-être
ouverte un jour au public ?